you know i've done a lot of videos on
testosterone and i've emphasized a lot
of things that can lower your
testosterone
but
in some recent research that i've been
diving into
sleep is a huge under emphasized factor
in your testosterone levels i want to
talk about that today now before i get
into the subject of sleep i want to just
touch on
some of the other things that can
dramatically lower your testosterone as
well because you need to know all of
them because what may affect one person
may not affect
everyone okay so the first thing you
need to know is that as you age
testosterone does go down however it's
not the major reason why someone has low
testosterone so let's first talk about
obesity if you are overweight
that can affect your testosterone why
because your fat cells
make this enzyme called aromatase and
aromatase turns your testosterone into
estrogen so the more fat you have on
your body the more estrogen you're going
to have
and there's this relationship between
testosterone and estrogen in that when
one goes up like estrogen the other one
goes down all right so the more fat you
have in your body the more estrogen
you're gonna have now there's a couple
other things that will increase your
estrogen too consuming a lot of soy
products okay that's one thing also
plastics i've done a video on this
and an average person consumes about a
credit card amount of plastic every
single week that's a lot of plastic to
be put in our bodies so you know we get
plastic from drinking out of plastic
bottles
cooking in plastic plastic is just all
over the place and that can increase our
estrogen as well now the other big
killer of testosterone is having high
insulin levels now you might think that
you have to be a diabetic to have high
insulin levels but that's not true
you could be a pre-diabetic or you can
have insulin resistance which i think
the majority of the population has and
that could be the reason why you have
low testosterone because you have high
levels of insulin see insulin is rarely
tested
normally they check blood sugars but
they don't look at insulin there's a
really good test to measure something
called insulin resistance that's called
homa ir that'll give you a lot of good
information on whether you have insulin
resistance and at the same time high
insulin so high insulin
low testosterone
now that relates to the next thing i'm
going to talk about which is your liver
the liver makes something called shb
g
sex hormone binding globulin now that's
an interesting word
that is a compound that
binds
to testosterone
and prevents it from being a free
testosterone that can go through the
body so it's something your body makes
to buffer
and
hold testosterone in an inactive form in
fact the great majority like 99
of your testosterone is locked up to
this protein and other proteins
so really you only have like one percent
of all your testosterone in a free state
that's available for you to use
99 of it is in a bound or locked up
state so the more that you have this
binding protein the less testosterone
you're going to have and so if there's
any problem with the liver as in a fatty
liver or it's inflamed or it's toxic it
can affect this part of this puzzle now
the next thing i want to talk about is
your adrenals okay the more adrenal
stress that you have the more cortisol
you have the less testosterone you're
going to have because
stress or cortisol inhibits testosterone
and as you age your adrenals kind of go
downhill where you don't produce enough
of the raw material to make these
adrenal hormones because testosterone is
also
one of the hormones that your adrenals
make and one of the precursor hormones
that help you make testosterone is
called dhea so if you're deficient in
that that raw material that could be one
reason why you don't have enough
testosterone and this probably mainly
relates to the aging process so that is
just one little side note something
maybe you could take as a supplement if
you've tried all these other factors and
it's still not working and this can
relate to both men and women if women
take too much of it they can get too
much testosterone if they take just a
small amount of it they can increase the
estrogen and progesterone so i just
wanted to make that side note the other
raw material that is needed to make
testosterone is cholesterol so if you're
on a low-fat diet or you are on statin
drugs that could be the reason that your
testosterone is low another factor is
iron if you have a condition where you
have too much iron in the body that can
negatively affect your testosterone how
do you know if you have too much iron
well you can get a blood test
also if you consume red meat and feel
worse or you take an iron supplement and
you feel worse
that could be another clue the other
factor in testosterone is something
called hypogonadism
where the testicles are atrophying or
shrinking okay and one of the causes for
that is aging another cause for that is
a zinc deficiency out of all the
nutrients
for testosterone
zinc is probably the most important one
and so you'd want to start eating foods
high in zinc and that would be shellfish
like oysters or even take a zinc
supplement and if you wanted a good zinc
supplement in a blend of trace minerals
i put that link down below all right
another factor with testosterone is
alcohol the more alcohol you have the
more estrogen you're going to have the
less testosterone you're going to have
especially when you drink beer but
all alcohol will create this effect all
right now the topic of sleep
sleep is vitally vitally important in
fact the research that i went through
which i'm going to put a link down below
demonstrates that the less sleep that
you have
the less testosterone you're going to
have because the way that your body
controls and manages testosterone are
through
circadian waves
and this means there's a crossover
between
your sleep especially the rem sleep okay
that's the second half of sleep
and the generation of testosterone in
fact if you generate more testosterone
the more rem sleep you have
so if you're only getting five hours of
sleep or less or even six hours or less
that could be the big reason why your
testosterone is low
so all the supplements all the zinc all
the things that you do including
testosterone replacement
are for
nothing if your sleep isn't good so your
testosterone correlates with your sleep
in one study it shows that if you can
get eight hours or more you're going to
have very good testosterone levels
also a lack of sleep increases cortisol
okay that's a stress hormone cortisol
directly will decrease testosterone and
cortisol also increases insulin which
will lower
testosterone so
a lack of sleep or a crappy sleep can
just destroy testosterone from so many
different angles so here's what i
recommend you do
number one
to help your sleep
more exercise
or better yet
physical work it can also directly
stimulate testosterone and improve your
sleep at the same time and exercise
improves insulin resistance and exercise
can help make you thinner less fat in
your body and exercise can help improve
your liver all right number two get off
the carbs carbs increase the insulin
carbs put you in a sympathetic dominant
mode okay which can decrease
testosterone because testosterone works
in a parasympathetic mode that doesn't
work that well when you're under stress
and so a low carb diet will help pull
you out of
this sympathetic dominance mode as well
as handle the insulin part of this
puzzle and also a low-carb diet will
greatly improve your liver and help
liver function and decrease the fat on
your liver as well number three improve
your sleep with improving the gut
microbiome i recently did a video on
drinking kefir
before bed or at the last meal of the
day okay a really good kefir gives you
good strains of both friendly bacteria
and friendly yeast
so fixing the gut biome is a very very
important action for sleep okay which
will then improve your testosterone and
you can even take a probiotic but the
gut is a very important factor in
sleeping better and then this as far as
sleep nutrients go
vitamin b1 from nutritional yeast that's
vital potassium and magnesium are two
physiological uh relaxers that are in
vegetables salads
or you can get an electrolyte powder to
help you sleep you don't want to take
the electrolyte power before you go to
bed but during the day can help calm you
down
and keep you in a relaxed mode and then
vitamin d before bed is a really good
action because vitamin d
greatly affects the circadian rhythms of
the body and of course i'm gonna also
recommend my own sleep aid before bed
i would take two
and then if you wake up in the middle of
the night okay take one
to help you get back to sleep to extend
your sleep for that eight hours
to maximize or optimize your sleep to
improve testosterone now i have some
additional information on sleep that's a
must i put that video up right here
check it out
you